that's when I was like you know what
maybe you're gay and little did I
realize I am very gay we had an email at
BuzzFeed asking us if there were any
moments that really defined our
sexuality or like kind of made us
realize who you are inside and I hadn't
really given it any thought and then it
came to that scene where that very like
hot tan almost like Grecian European
looking guy I cover whether he reaches
for his phone or who reaches over but he
like he reaches I remember literally
pausing it like on the button on the DVD
and being like play and that was it it
was like a brief little moment I had
with myself and I didn't touch myself or
anything like that but it was like hmm
that's nice you know that scene in Mulan
where she chops off all her hair and it
becomes a badass member of the army and
just like defies so many gender roles
that really did it for me realizing that
I was attracted to something so fluid
kind of scared me but also was super
exciting
I was just shown something I hadn't ever
seen before Thank You Mulan Oh her
helping this gay baby heart to find
herself I think when it was six or seven
I was watching a Ricky Martin concert on
TV with my family I distinctly remember
him singing livin la vida loca his shirt
was not on and I remember being like oh
okay I still love Ricky Martin it was
actually a pretty cool moment for me
when he came out this is somebody that I
grew up admiring I love this music
seeing kind of your childhood icon like
identify the same way that you do one of
my pop culture moments was when I was
watching que wills please don't
it is a Korean pop music video and it
has like a huge plot twist that was not
ready for it seems like the director was
shooting I said the guy was jealous of
the girl crazy thing is the guy actually
is falling for the group and it's like
mind blowing
I was like whoa so all this time he's
gay as a person of color as a person
that's from Asian descent this is a
topic that we don't really approach and
we don't talk about there's not much
representation in these roles so to see
someone that look like me that has
similar skin color as me and has same
facial structure as me that helped me in
terms of who I think gay
okay means to Who I am
so my gay awakening occurred when I was
watching Brokeback Mountain with my
parents this fairly explicit gay sex
scene was just like kind of happening I
was like oh what's going on here
seeing an example of gay intimacy
on-screen and realizing that that was
something I was curious and fascinated
by and interested in it was like
immediately paired with a moment of my
parents telling me that what I had just
started to see was bad
they made me leave the room and for the
record my parents let me watch straight
sex scenes so it wasn't just that it was
a sex scene it was that was a gay sex
scene I think before watching the sex
scene in Brokeback Mountain I did know
that I was gay but it wasn't something
that I was cognizant of it was something
that was definitely a little repressed
watching that scene help me realize
something that I already knew but was
afraid to admit to myself there's not
really that many like lesbian iconic
moments that made me realize like this
is also to how I feel anytime there was
like a strong female feed on whatever I
was watching I would just be like
obsessed and be like oh my god I love
her not in a gay way but also when I get
away probably pretty sure baby me had a
huge crush on Carmen from Spy Kids girl
was resourceful so intense and so just
like true to who she is but at the end
of the day is just like a softy and like
just wants to take care of juni and his
weird wart fingers and like I don't know
I think she's a really cool character
it's so weird to like look back and be
like those were such gay things going
through your head
[Music]